ah
you took everything from me
[Music]
it had to be done in times of great need
one must look up for advice if sven dies
this series is over i said it many times
oh great ikea tower
guide me give me hope
give me strength
give me reasons not to quit did you hear
that
oh
[Music]
all my friends are dead what do i do
i should plant 20 million trees in
minecraft
[Music]
that way i will get back all my friends
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
[Music]
okay gamers so to plant five billion
trees in minecraft
we're gonna need a lot of materials
okay so to plant 20 million trees that's
not gonna be easy
it's gonna be hard but i like things
that are hard
be quiet first we're gonna need bone
meal a lot of bone meal
it's gonna be a whole bone fest
and to do that we're gonna use the most
common
farm thing ever a zero tick farm yeah i
know xerotic farm everyone's
talking about it yeah yeah yeah
hey look holy oh
stop talking you're slaves you're slaves
remember your purpose
uh we're gonna put one hopper snapper
into the chastity pesky
then we put the composite posty there
and then we put the hopper snupper there
i build it too low
dang it hopper snooper composter
cluster then hopper into peepee
popper into pippy hopper into peepee
you put the rail you put the rail bling
bling blonde follow carefully listen
carefully
mine cards with hoppers on them flip
flap
plop remove the mine cards two
four and it's not perfect saying do you
like sans
of course you do put sand in them
do it do it
do it now we can plant cactus but not
yet
only fools would plant cactus on this
stage pistons mistin
here look carefully you stinky brainers
you're naked oh embarrassing you're
naked
look they're crying i think this is how
you do you put a note block right
i don't remember slime crime red dead
i should be a rapper or something and
then for whatever reason
oh that booty though and now we plant
the fill on trampy
and activate is it working
let's check it out
three bone meal we're gonna let that
chew
chew up a bit look at that speeding up
speeding up i like it i like it
while the bill bone meal is ticking
smicking we're gonna
get it down to the real business of
building 20 million trees i forgot to
mention why i'm
building 20 million trees obviously it's
mr b's
uh charity team trees
we're doing that for i i mean we're
doing it for to save all the animals
which makes perfect sense
i'm sure someone's already done planting
20 million trees but i doubt
anyone's done it the way we're about to
do it
i need to go back and get some materials
brb hey
why are you not getting fricked don't
stop
the freaking oh yeah it started lagging
my computer that's why
we're gonna need a lot of freaking
smoking clicking here
okay okay okay observers smurfers
servers pistons lots of pistons
how tall is a tree about as tall as my
height
in real life one two three four
yeah that should be tall enough it's a
dispenser is a dropper
i think it's dispenser so we put it
hey don't make that sexy face don't make
that
how is this legal in minecraft can
someone explain
bro this baby will shoot out
let's uh put this muti with the compis
monty
activate the play d
okay okay now you're annoying stop it
i know you're a sexy baby what's your
name mama
mama i'll call your mama nothing weird
about that
when tree grow it will activate
signal i guess we can put an observer
how do i do the redstone for that oh
yeah this is redstone episode
very epic okay so now
it work function
hey okay all right i will stand here
although i think we need a roof on it
right haha that's cute
give him a little uh little hat let me
just see if this actually works
let's check our bone meal is going
damn girl damn
remember with this when this show was
about friendship
and love okay let's try this
grow my child grow grow
grow what is your problem you're useless
i mean the worst tree i've ever seen
oh my god you're the why
oh it worked
yes does these fall off will they fall
eventually
oh and if we get hoppers underneath
then that means we can collect all the
peepee ooh
collect all peepee i like that i like
that
this is however just the beginning
okay this is going to take a long time
but it means we'll get a lot of bone
meat it's 20 million trees this is how
you do it
this is the most stinkiest brainiest
thing
hey oh wow that's super rare that's so
cool
dead you're dead you're dead
i wish your parents were here so they
could see what failures you are
okay so one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve epic now let's do that
four more times
yeah this is fun right we're having fun
you're having fun yeah you missed sven
well what do you think i'm doing this
for
why mr beast why could we not have found
better solution
okay okay i like it i like it i like it
uh we'll put an observer here and that
is going to
power as soon as it reaches here only
these are going to push so it's just
going to keep
20 million trees 20 million trees
yeah yeah yeah yeah 20 million trees
20 million trees easy easy
look at that that's a sweet sound of
bones being crushed god damn it
i just realized observer will activate
itself
once it reaches here
will it
damn it is um the most overly
complicated thing
but it just might work it's so good it
just might work
yes okay
maybe my brain is small but i think this
might just work
all right we're just gonna power
go away just gotta power so what we do
is we flip plop flip
okay follow carefully ping pong this way
we don't need uh
repeaters flip flop flip flop
and then we got to make the signal go up
like your mama's
smut i'm gonna put a repeater just to be
safe
because i'm all about that
why did i decide to do this
okay and then i'll go there
bing bong bing bong and then bing bong
all the way over here
you following me yeah bing bong all the
way all the way
all the way bing bang all the way
and i think that's it i think that's it
for the
piston bits look at this dude
it will it will make it asymmetric a
little bit but
uh hey but hey let's try it
okay planty plant
i guess it's not day so it might take
longer oh never mind
oh i grew too big happens to me all the
time
that was peepee joke in minecraft no it
didn't grow too big
these ones they're inactivated oh
it's just a slab here
there we go
yes all right we just gotta make sure it
works
until it gets there that's the scary bit
i need to do something about these as
well
okay looking good looking good oh god
i'm so scared
[Music]
damn it why do these not activate okay
now it work yes
papa
now we got to do something about these
bushes these filthy god them bushes oh
okay so now
i built them i built a monster it's a
monster oh my god i'm scared of it
will it work oh no it won't work there
damn it next
we're gonna put up a bunch of hoppers
mopper
making things a lot more unnecessarily
difficult
than it used needs to be all right
last one
last test i mean come on please work
uh kind of how did that happen
all right here we go last one it worked
sort though the last one let's see if i
can catch it
coming yep
please work
it worked yeah
there's so much he tries
slight problem tiny problem i can't
reach the chest i don't know why i put
it underneath
but now we have a fully functioning
yeah it looks spiders impressed don't
look oh
okay okay
now let's make 20 million of them cue
the montage
to save sven once and for all
bro okay
keep doing your thing girl
[Music]
there you have it folks
20 million trees
yeah it's 20 million okay hey marzia
what where'd she go okay so maybe it
wasn't 20 million trees but
this is as many as i can get let's talk
to fegi
once and for all ikea tower
i've done as you pleased i made 20
million trees in minecraft
i could probably make more if i just
planted them but
still fakie
what did i do
just go back my old save file
[Music]
oh my god why did you not say so
what is this old save file he's talking
about
that will never work oh my god
stop stop them
why am i so slow
oh my god
you're all here jurgen smirgin
hurry let's get out of here
[Music]
bing follow me there you go oh my god
yes
i missed you all so much french
boyfriend son
and sven that but why
why did you do this why did you leave me
for so long
you wanted to surprise me for my
birthday
you were all planning a party for me
but where is ulla britta la britta
my god
was that labrita
you found the recipe online for beetroot
cake
and beetroot told you that you should
all hide
to make a surprise party
what kind of what do you mean for my
30th birthday
what's that sven close your eyes bro
okay bro turn around bro
okay bro open your eyes bro
[Music]
oh my god thank you guys so much
look at the new ikea tower guys i built
it because it was lonely and sad
but now i am happy never leave me again
okay gamers check out team trees
save the planet smash like see you guys
next time bye bye
[Music]
you